[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin guten Abend das sportliche
in der Sendung übernimmt auch heute
wieder Christin Otto ja Fußball und
Handball guten Abend heute ist sehr viel
los und wir wollen es wieder für sie
sortieren unser
Überblick Aufruf der israelischen ee
eine Million Palästinenser sollen
umgehend ihre Häuser verlassen und
Außenministerin berbock fordert in
Israel die Geiseln
freiulassen erhöhte Gefährdungslage auch
in Deutschland wegen des Nahostkonflikts
werden die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
verstärkt und Deutsch schlecht English
quite good das zeigt eine Studie zur
Sprachkompetenz bei Schülerinnen und
Schülern der neunten Klasse
[Musik]
die Eskalation in Nahost hält die Welt
weiter in Atem Israel fordert Zivilisten
in Gaza auf sich in den Süden zu begeben
viele deuten das als Zeichen einer
bevorstehenden Bodenoffensive es wird
von Panik in der Bevölkerung berichtet
die islamistische Hamas die in Gaza das
Sagen hat fordert die Bewohner auf zu
bleiben soll sie sogar teilweise mit
Waffengewalt an der Flucht hindern über
die hochangespannte Situation Lena
sünderbruchs Luftangriffen kommen keine
Bomben vom Himmel sondern israelische
Flugblätter Gaza Stadt hat sich in ein
Schlachtfeld verwandelt steht dort sie
müssen ihre Häuser sofort verlassen und
sich südlich des gasabachtals begeben
dieses Tal befindet sich ungefähr in der
Mitte des gasastreifens 1,1 Millionen
Menschen leben nördlich dieser Linie
sollen in den Süden fliehen unmöglich
sagen die Vereinten Nationen und warnen
vor einer
Katastrophe es gibt keinen sicheren Ort
es gibt keinen einzigen Zentimeter wo
sich die Menschen sicher fühlen können
der gaserastreifen ist völlig
ungeschützt und es fehlt an
Infrastruktur für die
Grundversorgung Ärzte sehen den Aufruf
zur Evakuierung als Todesurteil für die
vielen Verletzten und är Grenzen fordert
die Ausweisung von sicheren Zonen für
Bevölkerungsgruppen die nicht fliehen
können und natürlich Krankenhäuser nach
dem Aufruf heute machen sich viele auf
den Weg esleib wo sie unterkommen die
Hamas nutzt zivile Einrichtungen als
Schutzschilde schon jetzt haben die
Menschen fast keine Lebensmittel mehr
kein Wasser keinen Strom Krankenhäuser
verwandeln sich in
Leichenhallen wir haben Angst an einen
anderen Ort zu gehen das israelische
Militär wird uns zerstören wir wissen
nicht wohin wir gehen sollen wir wissen
nicht was wir tun sollen heute werde ich
in meinem zerstörten Haus schlafen ich
werde hier niemals
weggehen es gibt Berichte dass die Hamas
Bewohner am Verlassen der
Evakuierungszone hindert Augenzeugen
sprechen von Panik im Norden des
Gazastreifens an einem der israelischen
Orte den die Hamas überfallen hat ist
Michael beverunge ins derot guten Abend
Michael von Panik ist die Rede und Hamas
soll palästinens palästinensische
Zivilisten an der Flucht hindern was
hörst du aus dem
Gazastreifen also dass die Hamas konkret
mit
straßensperrenbwohner an der Flucht
hindert kann ich nicht bestätigen ich
hatte heute die Gelegenheit mit einem
sehr zuverlässigen gewehrsmann in Gaza
zu telefonieren er konnte das nicht
bestätigen was nicht heißt dass das
vorkommt was er aber sehr deutlich
bestätigen konnte dass die Hamas
versucht die Informationen der
israelischen Armee zu konterkarieren das
als Falschmeldung darzustellen es wäre
gar nicht so schlimm und die Bevölkerung
zum Bleiben auffordert mein Gewährsmann
berichtet auch dass ein Großteil der
Bewohner Gaza City bereits verlassen hat
und nur der Teil zurückgeblieben ist die
unbedingt bei ihren Häusern bei ihrem
Eigentum bleiben wollte interessant auch
ich habe die frageestellt die wir immer
wieder besprechen wie steht die
Bevölkerung zu Hamas das ist natürlich
keine repräsentative Umfrage aber die
Stimme eines zuverlässigen Gewährsmann
der seit vielen Jahren da lebt er sagte
mit Sicherheit eine groß eine deutliche
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung hat die Nase
voll von Hamas auch von fatach von
jegler palästinensischen Führung die
dies Kriege durchführt und möchte
einfach nur in sen in Frieden und
Sicherheit leben Michael vielen Dank bis
hierher wir sprechen gleich noch mal
weiter heute viel internationale
Politprominenz in Israel sie alle
erklären sich solidarisch mahnen Israel
zur besondnenheit und versuchen auf
allen Kanälen etwas in der geiselfrage
zu bewegen in diesem Zusammenhang
appellierte Außenministerin berbock an
die Hamas die Geiseln freizulassen
gleichzeitig setzt Israel sein massives
Bombardement auf den nördlichen
Gazastreifen fort l
walpott Israel nimmt weiter Ziele in
Gaza unterbeschuss Hamas antwortet
weiter mit Raketen aus Gaza auf Israel
mittendrin die deutsche Außenministerin
auf solidaritätsbesuch in Netivot nahe
am Gazastreifen sichtlich berührt lässt
sich bbock von den israelischen
Gastgebern erläutern welches Leid die
Hamas Terrorattacken hinterlassen haben
wir fühlen mit denjenigen die geliebte
Menschen verloren haben oder immer noch
um das Leben ihrer Liebsten Bang ihr
Schicksal lässt uns keine Ruhe israel
habe das Recht und die Pflicht sich im
Rahmen des internationalen Rechts gegen
diesen brutalen barbarischen Terror zu
wehren so berbock israel hat unsere
umfassende
Solidarität und Israel hat unsere volle
Unterstützung die Hamas ist mit ihrem
Terror auf Israel ganz allein für diese
furchtbare Lage verantwortlich ebenso
deutlich wird usverteidigungsminister
Austin es gibt keine Rechtfertigung für
diesen Terror sagt er sein Amtskollege
gallant kündigt eine schwierige
Militäroperation
an wir werden die Hamas beseitigen die
militärische Gefahr an unserer Grenze
ausschalten das wird lange dauern mit
vielen Opfern aber wir müssen das ein
für alle Mal
beenden Sorge um die Opfer ein auch
diese deutschen Familien beim Treffen
mit Außenministerin bbock in telaviv
Hannan Kohen vermisst seine 79jährige
Schwester von der Hamas verschleppt der
einzige Wunsch den ich habe ist wieder
meine
Schwester und alle von uns jeder seine
Angehörigkeit an die
Familie wieder im Leben hier zu sehen
von margalet Moses gibt es seit Samstag
keine Nachrichten mehr aus
KiB wir wollen noch mal zu Michael Bunge
gehen nach sterot Michael viele mahnen
Israel zur besondnenheit auch
Außenministerin berbock heute
besondenheit und Krieg wie wie kann das
Zusammenpassen also eine humanitäre
Kriegsführung letztendlich ist das ein
unauflösbarer Widerspruch das weiß auch
die Außenministerin wenn sie feststellt
dass die Hamas benut bewusst Schulen
Supermärkte Hospitäler mit den Menschen
darin als menschlich Schutzschilde
benutzen wird
wenn man das Ziel wirklich erreichen
will die Hamas nachhaltig zu zerschlagen
dann geht kein Weg an einer umfassenden
Bodenoffensive vorbei und dann wird es
so oder so viele viele zivile Opfer
geben danke schön nach sterot Michael
bwerunge mit Sorge blickten heute viele
auf die Reaktion der Muslime weltweit
nach ihrem traditionellen Freitagsgebet
weil die islamistische Hamas aufrief zum
Tag des Zorns wie sie es nennt Proteste
rund um den Globus wie hier in Kapstadt
in Südafrika oder auch in Indonesien
also dem Land mit den weltweit meisten
Muslimen meist friedlich besonders groß
war die Sorge vor Gewalt in den
arabischen Ländern mehr dazu von Anna
Feist symbolische flaggenverbrennung die
Terrororganisation Hamas hat gerufen zum
Freitag der alxa Flut das war auch der
codname der Terrorattacken gegen is
im IR sus dem ru gefolgt ihr Protest für
Gaza ist auch eine Demonstration ihrer
Bereitschaft zum
Kampf wir wollen die Palästinenser
unterstützen in ihrem Kampf gegen den
zionistischen
Feind am Rande der Proteste wird
eingekauft wir wollen hier militärisches
Zubehör kaufen vorbet sein unterdessen
bringt sich auch
iranellung sich der iranische
Außenminister im Libanon an diesem
Vormittag mit dem Führer der hbollah
nasrala getroffen die von Iran gelenkte
und vom Westen als Terrororganisation
eingestufter hbolla hält sich bisher
zurück das könne sich aber jederzeit
ändern wenn die organisierten
Kriegsverbrechen von dem Regime in
Israel nicht sofort aufhören dann ist
alles
möglich versmel sich
die Anhänger der hisboll mit Parolen die
die Kampfbereitschaft der
Terrororganisation bezeugen sollen doch
einigen hier geht das nicht weit
genug wir wollen keine Worte wir wollen
Aktion sehen aufgeheizte Stimmung zwar
doch bisher bleiben zumindest die
Proteste vielerorts weitgehend
friedlich Wut und Proteste werden auch
bei uns in Deutschland befürchtet
deswegen verstärkte die Polizei heute
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen entsprechende
Warnungen auch vom Bundeskriminalamt
viele jüdische Einrichtungen blieben
vorsichtshalber geschlossen Markus
gross wieder Proteste von Palästinensern
am Nachmittag in Neuköln trotz
demoverbots die Polizei schnell vor Ort
Festnahmen die Stimmung
aufgeheizt mehr Sicherheit zum Schutz
der Synagogen und jüdischen
Einrichtungen erhöhte Gefährdungslage
nach den Gewaltaufrufen der
Terrororganisation Hamas jüdische
Familien lassen ihre Kinder heute zu
Hause schicken sie nicht zur
Schule die Sorge ist groß dass
irgendetwas passiert aber es ist klar
wir dürfen uns als Gesellschaft da auch
nicht lähmen lassen dagegen halten ein
Zeichen der Solidarität senden
Bundespräsident Steinmeier zu Besuch in
einer Berliner Synagoge der
schutzjüdischen Lebens habe höchste
Priorität wer Deutscher ist oder auf
Dauer in unserem Land leben will
muss Auschwitz kennen und Begreifen der
muss die Geschichte kennen die uns in
besonderer Art und Weise mit Jüdin und
Juden und auch mit dem Staat Israel
verbindet die Freitagsgebete in
Deutschland bleiben friedlich der Imam
in dieser Kölner Moschee ruft so einem
miteinander auf verurteilt den Terror
der Hamas es ist halt so dass Religionen
nicht zum Krieg aufrufen nicht zum
Blutvergießen aufrufen und wenn dann
irgendeine Terrorgruppe oder Extremisten
sagen so im Namen Gottes oder im Namen
dieser Religion haben wir das gemacht
oder wir feiern das das das tut weh
Berlin am Abend Mahnwache vor einer
Synagoge als Zeichen der Solidarität für
die Opfer des
terrorangriffs jetzt eine Meldung zum
russischen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
das Nordkorea Russland dabei unterstützt
war schon länger vermutet worden jetzt
nennt die US-Regierung konkrete Zahlen
demnach habe Nordkorea mehr als 1000
Container mit militärischer Ausrüstung
und Munition an die Russen
geliefert Zuwanderung nach Deutschland
muss künftig besser gesteuert und
kontrolliert werden das fordern auch die
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder gerade in
diesem Moment besprechen Sie das Thema
mit dem Kanzler ihre Vorschläge
schnellere Asylverfahren etwa oder
weniger Bargeld für Flüchtlinge Stefan
Schlösser
berichtet monang hat sich die
Bevölkerung gegen die Errichtung der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in ihrem Ort upal
gewehrt ohne Erfolg mittlerweile sind
die ersten 150 Bewohner eingezogen die
Überforderung der Kommunen wird hier
überdeutlich wir haben schlichtwg ab ja
Anfang Dezember keine weiteren
unterkunftsplätze und wie wir dann
Verfahren das werde ich dem inminister
dann mitteilen und sagen dass ich voll
bin auf der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in
Frankfurt stand das Thema Migration ganz
oben auf der Agenda wirind entschlossen
alle miteinander unseren Teil dazu
beizutragen um in einer wirklich
schwierigen Zeit das Vertrauen von
BürgerInnen Bürger in die Demokratie und
unsere politische Ordnung zu erhalten
und auch zurückzugewinnen gemeinsam
fordern die Länderchefs stärkere
Maßnahmen zur Begrenzung der
Flüchtlingsströme so sollen Asylbewerber
ohne Bleibeperspektive innerhalb von dre
Monaten ausgewiesen werden statt
Geldleistungen soll möglichst eine
Bezahlkarte zum Einsatz kommen um
Geldüberweisungen ins Ausland zu
unterbinden Deutschland soll
unattraktiver werden wie kriegen wir es
hin dass weniger nach Deutschland kommen
bzw die die kein bleiberechte
zurückgeführt werden ähm und trotzdem
bleibt die zweite Frage natürlich und
das ist die Frage nach dem Geld wir
müssen insbesondere und da verhandeln
wir als Länder für die Kommunen dafür
sorgen dass wir ein atmendes System
wieder bekommen heißt mehr Geld bei
steigenden Zahlen weniger bei sinkenden
Zahlen zur Stunde sprechenende reinen
und weil zusammen mit Friedrich Merz und
Olaf Scholz im Kanzleramt das Thema
Migration braucht eine Partei über
übergreifende
Lösung wir gehen nach Berlin zu Theo K
Theo in diesen Minuten geht die Sitzung
mit dem Ministerpräsidenten und dem
Kanzler los worauf könnte es
hinauslaufen ich glaube es dürfte auf
ein bewusst breites politisches Signal
hinauslaufen und das Signal lautet
Wähler wir haben die Botschaft vom
vergangenen Sonntag von den
Landtagswahlen verstanden heute werden
zwar keine konkreten Beschlüsse erwartet
aber es ist allen Beteiligten klar dass
es so nicht weitergeht und die
bisherigen migrationsmaßnahmen und
Verfahren nicht ausreichend sind die
Ministerpräsidenten haben ja
beispielsweise den Vorschlag gearbeitet
das Asylverfahren längstens dre Monate
dauern dürfen jedenfalls für geflüchtete
aus denjenigen Staaten die eine
Anerkennungsquote von unter 5% haben
damit könneen schnell mehr erreicht
werden als mit der ganzen Debatte über
sichere Herkunftsstaaten meinte heute
Ministerpräsident weil außerdem fordern
die Länderchefs neben der erwähnten
Umstellung auf eine Bezahlkarte für die
Asylbewerber auch für ihre eigenen
Aufgaben deutlich mehr Geld vom Bund der
Kanzler hat da schon Flexibilität
angekündigt und der Entscheidungstermin
ist auf den 6 November festgelegt also
da ist Bewegung drin danke schön the Kol
nach Berlin wie Schleuser das Leben von
Migranten aufs Spiel setzen zeigt ein
dramatischer Unfall auf der A94 in
Oberbayern dort überschlug sich am
Morgen ein Fahrzeug mit 23 Menschen
sieben wurden getötet darunter ein
sechsjähriges Kind der Fahrer des Wagens
versucht einer Polizeikontrolle zu
entgehen und beschleunigte auf bis Tempo
180 als er von der Autobahn abfahren
wollte verlor er die Kontrolle gegen den
24-Jährigen statenlosen wird jetzt unter
anderem wegen eines Tötungsdelikts
ermittelt an einer Schule in der
nordfranzösischen Stadt Aras ist ein
Lehrer getötet worden mutmaßlich von
einem ehemaligen Schüler zwei weitere
erwachsene wurden verletzt der Täter
laut Polizei ein Russe tchenischer
Herkunft wurde festgenommen der
20-Jährige stand auf einer Liste von
gefährdern Frankreichs Präsident macron
sprach vor Ort vom islamistischen Terror
und sagte dass die Polizei zudem in
einer anderen Region einen weiteren
Anschlagsversuch vereitelt habe die
antiterrorstaatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt nach Deutschland zu einer
neuen Bildungsstudie fangen wir an mit
der guten Nachricht neun klässler sind
besser in Englisch geworden jetzt die
Sch ihr Schulabschluss ist öfter
gefährdet denn sie schwächeln in Deutsch
z. be beim Lesen da ist das gemessene
Niveau gesunken
-9% Punkte im Vergleich zu 2015 auch bei
der Rechtsschreibung ein deutlicher
Rückgang um 12% Punkte und sehr viel
schlechter läuft es beim Zuhören hier
ein Minus von 19% Punkten dazu Roman
lesk Deutschunterricht einer neunen
Klasse am Berliner K Gymnasium dass die
Ergebnisse im Kernfach schlecht
ausgefallen sind überrascht die
Schulleitung nicht z Jahre
coronapandemie samt Homeschooling haben
Spuren hinterlassen die Schülerinnen und
Schüler haben zu Hause in erster Linie
dann vielleicht kurze Textnachrichten
geschrieben ohne Grammatik ohne ohne
längere längere Inhalte ja und genauso
waren auch die Texte die sie gelesen
haben weiterer Grund für die
Verschlechterung könnte laut Studie der
wachsende Anteil von Schülern mit
Zuwanderung und sein in Deutsch seinen
sie benachteiligt der Handlungsbedarf
für das wichtige Hauptfach sei groß wir
müssen unbedingt den Fokus stärker auf
die Sicherung von Basiskompetenzen legen
lesen schreiben und zuhören wir brauchen
unbedingt eine verbesserte
Sprachförderung gerade auch für Kinder
und Jugendliche die mit sehr geringen
Deutschkenntnissen ins System kommen
deutlich verbessert zeigen sich die
Schüler im Fachenglisch hier könnte der
erhöhte außerschulische Medien Konsum in
der Pandemie positiv gewirkt haben
bestätigt sich auch an der Berliner
Schule davor habe ich gefühlt nie ein
englisches Video geguckt aber seit der
coronapandemie schaue ich mir mal
häufiger auch englische Videos an ich
denke schon dass dadurch dass ich halt
einfach öfter höre dass es dann auch
besser wird weil wenn man es hört dann
merkt man sich es ja auch besser positiv
vermeldet der Bildungsbericht zuudem bei
den Deutsch und Englisch Lehrern sie
sind überwiegend sehr zufrieden mit
ihrem Job und das trotz des
lehrerms
für Sie geht's jetzt auch weiter mit
außerschulischen Medienkonsum wir sind
beim Sport Christin morgen das Spiel
Deutschland gegen USA
Fußballnationalmannschaft gibt einen
neuen Trainer und der setzt wohl auf
Erfahrung in den USA ja ziemlich klug
wie ich finde morgen abend also Fußball
jetzt das ist deine Überleitung die ich
hier sehe wir haben gerade ein kleines
technisches Problem Julian nagesmann
möchte Spieler die Verantwortung
übernehmen deswegen braucht er auch
ältere Typen wie Matz hummes z.B
Weltmeister 2014 der nach mehr als 27
Monaten ohne länderspiel spel in die
Abwehr der Nationalmannschaft
zurückkehrt Hummels und Müller sind zwei
der insgesamt 12 Spieler im Kader die
zur Ü30 Generation zählen Routine und
Reife sind also wieder Trumpf Hummels
kann sein Comeback kaum erwarten war ein
großes Ziel von mir wieder herzukommen
ich bin sehr glücklich sehr stolz dass
das geklappt hat und unendlich froh hier
wieder mit dabei zu sein der 34-Jährige
ist überzeugt vom neuen Chef der nur Z
Jahre älter ist als er selbst hungrig
erfolgshungrig also er hat richtig Lust
auf das ganze hier
hat klare Vorstellung von seinem Spiel
ist sehr detailliert Hummels beim BVB
konstant gut körperlich auf Topniveau
steht vor seinem 77 Länderspiel und wird
in der Startelf erwartet Kimmich dagegen
fällt wohl wegen einer Erkältung
aus Sieg verbucht doch noch fehlt der
Glanz die deutschen Handballerinnen sind
in Wetzler erfolgreich in die EM
Qualifikation gestartet 31 Z 24 gegen
die Ukraine ein durchwachsener Auftritt
vor allem zu Beginn echt
häbrig zunächst merkt man ihn die
fehlende gemeinsame Spielpraxis an
Deutschlands Handballerinnen lassen sich
von den Ukrainerinnen überrumpeln und
gaten schnell mit fünf Toren in
Rückstand dass wir am Ende mit sieben
Toren gewinnen trotz fünf Tore Rückstand
zwischendurch ist auch ein
Qualitätsmerkmal die Qualität sie kommt
mit Verzögerung schneller Gegenstoß über
die Kapitänin und Marin Weigel bringt
das Team erstmals in Führung nach der
Pause sieht Bundestrainer gaugisch eine
bessere Vorstellung der Vorsprung wird
ausgebaut bis zum Endstand von 31 z24
das für morgen vorgesehene nächste EM
Qualifikationsspiel in Israel ist aus
nachvollziehbaren Gründen verschoben
worden ja gibt wichtigeres als Sport
danke dir Christin nach der Wärme heute
kommt in der Nacht der Winter zu regen
und spätestens Sonntag die Kälte
genaueres gleich von Katja hornefa um 22
Uhr begrüßt Sie Anne gellineek zum
heutejournal schönen Start ins
Wochenende und bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend das war ein
rekordfreitag noch nie war es seit
Beginn regelmäßiger Wetteraufzeichnung
in Deutschland
1881 so spät im Jahr so warm und noch
nie gab es so spät im Jahr noch mal
einen heißen Tag wie in Mülheim und den
Rheinfelden mit
30,1° dahinter steckte ein Tief das
brachte aus Südwesteuropa noch mal die
Wärme heran es gab auch viel
Sonnenschein und viel Wind jetzt aber
wird sich das Wetter ändern mit einer
Kaltfront die liegt etwa um Mitternacht
zwischen dem niederrein und femahn davor
kommt der windner aus südwestlichen
dahinter aus nordwestlichen Richtungen
wir erwarten schwere sturmböhen an der
Küste und auf dem Brocken im Harz sogar
orkanbö mit dieser Kaltfront kommt viel
Regen heran der ist zum Teil mit gewi
durchsetzt im Südosten ist es klar die
Nachttemperaturen liegen zwischen 18 und
9° und morgen übertag wird's kaum wärmer
uns erwarten 12 bis 22° morgen kommen
neue kräftige Schauer und Gewitter von
der Nordsee heran dann gibt's einen sehr
freundlichen Streifen vom niederrein bis
zur oda und die kalt von der Nacht zieht
weiter nach Süden da regnet es also noch
länger zum Teil gibt's da auch Gewitter
und sehr wechselhaft wird dann auch der
Sonntag bei nur noch 7 bis 15° guten
Abend